[موسيقى]
ما أريد قوله أولاً هو
أنني وعائلتي والعديد من الإيرانيين
نشعر بالامتنان
للرئيس الراحل صدى للحكومة
المصرية وللسيدة
السادات والآن أيضًا
عندما لم يستقبلنا العالم كله.
في بلدك الجميل
وأنا ممتن أيضًا للرئيس
السيسي ، الحكومة المصرية
والشعب المصري الذين تمكنوا من القدوم طوال
هذه السنوات إلى مصر والقاهرة الجميلة ،
وأردت
أن أضيف
أنني ممتن
لمصر والشعب المصري
و  أيضا الرئيس الراحل السادات
لأن السيدة السادات أخبرتني
قبل بضع سنوات عندما أتيت إلى هنا
الرئيس السادات
عندما
اتصل به الرئيس كارتر
قال له
جيمي أريد الصدمة هنا وعلى قيد الحياة
وبعد فترة لم
يرغب الرئيس كارتر في ذلك.  تحدث معه
ولم يرغب الرئيس صدى في التحدث
إليه ، فقد طلب من السيد مبارك الإجابة
، ثم
أردت أيضًا أن أكون ممتنًا جدًا
للشعب المصري لأنه عندما
جئنا إلى هنا
جاء صحفيون أجانب جدًا إلى
الناس ما يشعرون
به والشعب المصري في
الشوارع مرحب به وقد
ساعدنا خلال
الحرب وأردت أن أقول إنني
ممتن للشعب المصري
ما أريد أن أقوله هو بعد
42 عامًا الآن و  بعد 43 عامًا من ما
حدث في إيران
والذي أثر فيني كثيرًا هو أن
الكثير من الإيرانيين وخاصة الشباب
يقولون شعارات
مثل أه
للشاه شاه رو ، مما يعني
إظهار روحك نحن على قيد الحياة
وهناك العديد من الشباب على وجه الخصوص
هم  لقد غسلوا دماغ
معظمهم الآن بسبب الإنترنت
لأن والديهم أخبرهم
بما يحدث في إيران ،
فهم
يحترمون حقًا ذكرى الشاه
ويفكرون فيه
جيدًا ، أنت تعلم أنني دائمًا ما أحافظ على الأمل
وهناك الكثير من البؤس في إيران
قتل
فساد السجن
والوضع الرهيب للمرأة في
إيران وهناك كما سمعت
مظاهرات على الرغم من أن في أجزاء مختلفة
من إيران من قبل المعلمين والعمال
والمزارعين  د
جميع العمال
لأن
الناس تعرف بلدًا غنيًا جدًا
مثل شعب إيران ،
فإن غالبية الناس ليس لديهم
ما يكفي من الطعام
وعليهم أن
ينام الناس على القبور
في المقابر
ويعمل الأطفال
وحتى بعض الأشخاص يبيعون أطفالهم
هناك  الكثير من البؤس
وما أؤمن به دائمًا أن التغيير سيحدث
من الداخل وهناك الكثير
من الفساد في هؤلاء الناس
ومن ثم
إيران التي كانت دولة عظيمة ذات
حضارة عظيمة
يحترمها البلدان من حولنا ينظر
جيراننا وبقية
العالم  ما أصبح عليه اليوم
بشكل جيد
نأمل أن آمل أن يحدث في
المستقبل تغييرات
إيران لا يوجد مقارنة
لأن
ما يحدث اليوم في إيران كل
هذه
السنوات الـ 44 لا أستطيع أن أصدق كل
المشاكل التي مر بها الإيرانيون
واحترامهم  إيران في الشرق الأوسط
وبقية
العالم وفي
إيران أقول دائمًا إنك تعلم أن البلدان
تغير الحكومة والنظام
الذي يأتون ولكن كيف يمكن أن أعني
بلد مثل إيران من سايروس العظيم
يأتي إلى
هؤلاء الأشخاص
الآن
ولا توجد مقارنة حول ،
لا أقول إننا لم نواجه مشاكل
لم تكن لدينا عيوب
ولكن في الحقيقة لم يكن ذلك من
وجهة نظري  نقطة للوصول إلى هذا
الوضع
هناك
مقارنة بالطبع
ثم
لا أوافق أيضًا لأنه يجب أن يحدث
من الداخل
لا أنا
خطير إنه
خطر على دول الخليج الفارسي على
الشرق
الأوسط وهي لعبة شخصية خطيرة جدًا
ضد.  أي أسلحة نووية
[موسيقى
] هل تعلم
أنه يتعين علينا أحيانًا اتخاذ قرار
ليس في وسعنا
، وبعد ذلك ما حدث من بلد
إلى آخر كان ابني رضا يدرس
هناك
ثم مكث هناك وأراد القدوم إلى
أوروبا ولكن  لم يكن ذلك
ممكنًا ،
لكن يجب أن أقول ما حدث في إيران ،
ولا أقول إننا لم نواجه مشاكل في الداخل ،
ولكن بمساعدة
دول أجنبية مثل
بريطانيا
العظمى وفرنسا
على وجه الخصوص ، ساعدوا في هذه الخطوة  منة
أن يحدث
ولكنك تعرف أن كل
بلد يسعى وراء
مصلحته الخاصة لأشياء مختلفة ،
لذا
فهم لا يهتمون بالنظام في
البلد طالما أنهم يحصلون على ما يريدون
ولكننا نأمل
أن يكون هناك عدد كافٍ من الحكماء
لفهمهم  أن هذا النظام في
بلدنا الآن يمثل خطرًا على السلام في
الشرق الأوسط والمنطقة
الآن أنا أؤيد ما فعله لأنه
في
الوقت الحالي يا إلهي
43 عامًا يقاتل من أجل الحرية
في
إيران وأنا أؤيده ومرات عديدة أسأل
رأيه
عندما يتعين علي إجراء مقابلات وأقول
شيئًا أو شيءًا آخر لأنني
أريد أن أكون في طريقه وما يقوله
دائمًا هو
أنه يريد
بلدًا يتمتع
بوحدة أراضي وحرية
ديمقراطية للمرأة وحقوق
الإنسان والأمر متروك للشعب
الإيراني  ما يريدون
ما قلته بالضبط هو ما يشعر
أنه يحب بلاده أبناء وطنه
وهو يقول للشعب الإيراني
عندما يتمتعون بالحرية ، فالأمر
متروك لهم لتحديد نوع
الحكومة و
أنا شخصياً أؤمن
بالملكية الدستورية ،
لكن الأمر متروك للناس ليقرروا ما
يريدون
مشاركته سيكون
مختلفًا لأن الأوقات مختلفة
في العالم وفي المنطقة
و  زوجي الراحل ، صاحب الجلالة الراحل ،
أراد أن ينفتح في النهاية ،
لكننا لم
نكن أقصد العودة
كما تعلم
مع ما إذا كان يمكنك وضع باريس في
زجاجة ماء ،
فهناك ما نفكر فيه
ولكن في  في النهاية ، أراد أن ينفتح أكثر
ولكن حسنًا ،
أعتقد أن الملكية
هي والد الأمة
ومن ثم
كان لدينا اتصال مع عرقيات
مختلفة في جزء مختلف من إيران
ويجب أن تبقى إيران في قطعة واحدة
وأنا بالطبع لست سعيدًا
عندما
أرى بعض الدول
تدفع
أجزاء مختلفة من إيران للانفصال ولكن ما
آمل أن تكون إيران في
قطعة واحدة ودولة واحدة
هي
إيران ،
الأمر لا يتعلق بالمعارضة في
الخارج خاصة في إيران
القوية ،
ولا أعرف لست قوية بما فيه الكفاية ولكن
ذ  هناك مجموعات كثيرة وهناك
يتحدثون عن حقوق إيران في
إيران وحالة الناس حالة
المرأة
ونأمل أن
تدعم الدول المهمة فكرة الحرية هذه
في
إيران وبالطبع الشعب الإيراني
أولئك الذين يعارضون النظام
سعداء.  أن هناك بعض المجموعات
بالخارج تدعمهن
هو مستقبل النساء الإيرانيات ، وأعتقد
أنه سيكون لديهن الحرية ، يجب أن
أخبرك بشيء أخذته من الإنترنت
وقمت بنسخه وهو مدخل
شقتي في باريس في إيران.
فكر حتى هنا عندما يكون شخص
ما قويًا يقولون إنه رجل محظوظ
ومكتوب باللغة الفارسية مع
علم إيران باللون الأخضر والأبيض والأحمر إذا
كنت رجلاً ، فتأتي إلى إيران وتصبح
امرأة ،
فهي
أقوى من الرجل.  في إيران
ويظهرون ذلك الآن في
ظل هذا الاضطهاد
والديكتاتوريات كما تعلمون أننا في إيران شيعة وقد
سمعت أن أيديولوجية السنة
هي
نفسها تقريبًا التي يريدون أن يكون
لها دين.  الحكومة الأمريكية
[موسيقى]
لذلك تجدون أوجه التشابه
الحمد لله إن
مصر بلد عظيم به مثل هذه
الحضارة
العظيمة وآمل أن
تظل دائمًا مسالمة
أم
لا ، كما تعلم ،
كنت أرغب دائمًا في أن أكون
إيجابيًا
في الحياة
وأن أكون ممتنًا لما لدي.
وبالطبع المآسي التي
تعرضت
لها عائلتي
كانت كثيرة
ولكنك تعلم أنه حتى في تلك الأوقات الصعبة
عندما كان جلالته على قيد الحياة
على الرغم من أنهم قالوا الكثير من
الأشياء السلبية عنه كنت أعرف من هو وكنت
أعرف من أنا
حتى لو  كانت الصحافة
لسببهم الخاص ضدهم
وأنت تعلم
أنني أردت أن أكون
هناك من
أجل أطفالي للاحتفاظ بالأجانب
لأولئك الذين
لديهم عاطفة لي
وأنت تعلم
أن تكون ممتنًا لما لدي في الحياة ،
كنت أرغب دائمًا في أن أكون
إيجابيًا.
لقد قلت إن الاستراتيجيات التي أملكها سيئة
ولكنني أردت أن
تعرف أنك
فكرت في مواطني بلدي الذين
عانوا كثيرًا
ولا أعرف ربما تكون هذه هي الطريقة
التي نشأت بها ، فقد كنت فتاة
كشافة  ProjectSyndicate ar
لكي أكون إيجابيًا
وأن أكون ممتنًا لما لدي
وأنا أفكر دائمًا في ذلك على الرغم من
أنني أعني أن هناك الكثير من البؤس في
بقية العالم للعديد من الملايين
من الناس
عندما أنام في سريري بسلام ، فإنني
أشكر الله عندما  أتناول طعام الغداء والعشاء ،
أفكر في هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين
ليس لديهم أي شيء ليأكلوه
، ولهذا السبب يبقيني مستمراً وإن
شاء الله ، آمل أن يذهب ،
أملي هو أن تتخلص إيران من هذا
النظام ولديها  نظام ديمقراطي سلمي
بالطبع
إذا
تمكنت يومًا ما من العودة إلى
بلدي فسيكون يومًا رائعًا
لا تفقد الأمل ،
حافظ على الأمل
، لقد تم غزو إيران من قبل العديد من
الدول الأجنبية ولكن الإيرانيين يظلون إيرانيين دائمًا
وهؤلاء الناس  أنا أعتبرهم أيضًا
أجانب وليس إيرانيين ،
لذا احتفظ بالأمل
على الرغم من أنني أعلم أنك تعاني
كثيرًا
لدرجة أنني أقول دائمًا إن
النور سيتغلب على الظلام
وستشرق إيران من رمادها غريبًا
[موسيقى]
أنت